[Music]
my question is for josh
you and your wife have separate
residences in different states
does this mean that you both have
duplicate items in your homes and how
does that work into the minimalist
lifestyle so let me start by saying
michelle clearly you're not caught up on
the podcast
from like three months ago
no no she just called in this week
anyway um
michelle i'm just kidding but
here's what i'll say is yeah becks and i
do live separately although we don't
live in separate states anymore we did
live in separate states for five years
at least we lived in separate states
half the time so we were together half
the time we were apart half the time and
that rhythm seems to work pretty well
for us maybe not week on week off but
two days on two days off etc works well
for us that's a rhythm that i'm not
prescribing to anyone else although i
would encourage folks to notice
if a rhythm that they're currently in
isn't working for them
instead of trying to force that rhythm
to work for you
why not simply change the rhythm however
that's not what your question is about
your question is about duplicate things
and this presupposes that duplicates
are necessarily a bad thing
now i have
probably 10 pairs of underwear
they're all duplicates
fraud
and and so what i will say is that
something being duplicate isn't a bad
thing and so the heart of your question
though is well maybe if you live
together full time
then you could get by with fewer things
and i would acknowledge that yeah
michelle if you and i lived together we
would get
by with fewer things i would have to buy
less
toothpaste
i wouldn't have to have two tubes of
toothpaste we could just share the same
tube right in fact if all of the people
here in this room we have danny in
alabama and we have professor sean and
jordan no more and ryan and tk and me if
we all just lived in you know a frat
house together
it could be so much coffee a new reality
show idea
and it's like we all own nothing
anyway what we would have fewer
duplicates but our lives would be
markedly worse for us right especially
for me and so i think we have to take
that into account now here's the funny
thing is the same tube of toothpaste
like yeah i might have a tube of
toothpaste at my place and bex has a
tube of toothpaste at her place and but
if we just had one tube of toothpaste we
use it twice as quickly right and so yes
there's nothing inherently wrong with
duplicates in fact i think if you come
to my house you're gonna say oh wow
this is
yeah you don't own much right
but i own some things that might
duplicate what is going on at bex's
house she's her own individual i'm an
individual and so we have our own
individual needs and there's nothing
wrong with that a better question for me
is
does this thing add value to my life
does it serve a purpose does it bring
out the joy in me in some way does it
amplify or enhance my experience of life
if so wonderful
if not then i'm going to let it go
regardless of whether or not it is it's
a duplicate
yeah what i hear in michelle's question
is like hey you've got a set of pots and
pans at your place you probably need
pots and pans over at bex's place too
and uh i mean you you two live much
closer together now so um yeah there
might be some things that you used to
have duplicates of that you no longer
have duplicates of
yeah yeah and that will always continue
to be true as
as i assess what adds value to my life
yeah you're right bex owns a whole lot
more kitchenware than right i do right
yeah and if someone's going to cook
dinner you're probably going to go to
bex's
cook some dinner or no i cook it by
myself but i have one skillet right
right and that's all i need for me right
and so and if if bex wants to cook great
then i'll go over there and she can cook
we're still living together about half
the time we found that rhythm that works
for us but because that rhythm works for
us the time apart yes it does require
some things that i otherwise wouldn't
have but i'm not willing to make myself
miserable in order to simply own fewer
things that's not what minimalism is
that's not the heart of minimalism tk we
were talking about this before we
started recording you were trying to see
an announcement on twitter and you
noticed some tweet that popped up yeah
it was so interesting um that there was
a quote where you talked about
consumerism
and and and someone says
well well you know like you guys sell
books and and things like that and you
have a podcast
and um and i forgot your response but it
was something like there's a difference
between
conscious consumption and consumerism
right and um and it was interesting
because what was overlooked in in that
response to you is that
anytime you add the word add the letters
ism after anything and you turn it into
an ism that ism changes everything yeah
you know to put a ism afterward means
that we're not just gonna talk about
that word we're gonna talk about a
lifestyle in which everything that you
do is oriented around that word so
consumption is human consumerism is
anti-human right those are two different
things and so i i think
you know um
this question is it's it's a little
similar to uh other questions i've had
people ask me like so the minimalists
living in california that doesn't sound
very minimalistic california is a really
expensive place and so people have this
impression that you know if you're a
minimalist you have to live as
inexpensively as possible you got to
find the cheapest place the fewest
amount of things and
it's it's less about the quantity of
things that you have and it's about
understanding that efficiency is about
optimizing for what makes you the best
version of yourself and there are things
that you could do in the name of owning
less stuff that could actually make you
more inefficient and less happy and less
effective in other areas of life you
know you talked about the owning one
pair of underwear versus ten pairs well
if you own one pair of underwear but
you're doing laundry every single day
well that's wasteful in another way
right so everything has opportunity
costs so you always got to ask that
question compared to what it's easy to
say hey man if you all live together you
would have fewer things but what are the
other costs you'd be paying in order to
live together and how might that
compromise your ability to serve that's
why we got to think about things in
terms of what makes us better what holds
us back not the number of things that
are involved yeah i
i think it's funny that people
think that we don't see the irony in
everything we do
everything that we do is blanketed by
iran yes everything and you know one
thing too that i've had to um
shift my perspective on it is like you
know putting some products out there
some physical products
and uh you know we've done that with our
books we've done that with um the bag
that uh we partnered with malcolm
fontier with pact
um
you know all that to say is i've had to
realize that like every single one of us
we are selling something every single
one of us
we're not no one is not selling
something
and the question is is what are you
selling and is it meaningful so when i
think about the books when i think about
you know the bag it's like these are
some really high quality like i'm very
proud to be like wow look what we made
um
and and yeah i mean it's if you if you
go if you come at minimalism with don't
consume don't produce
well you're a hermit like that's that's
what that is and that's and that's okay
there's nothing wrong with that
um but yeah it's interesting because
it's it's when someone makes a judgment
like that whoa you sell books and blah
blah i can't even like give it a serious
response
because
it's like they're saying what they want
to see
and that's okay they can see whatever
they want to see yeah i remember
my mom once told me
don't answer an unserious question with
a serious answer right
and that's so good
quite often what we will do is
we'll have someone approach us with a
criticism and i'm not i'm not going to
throw out a blanket statement like all
these haters or critics or whatever
trolls
that that stuff doesn't
mean anything to me like um i think
those are
those are thought terminating cliches as
well to dismiss someone oh it's just a
troll no it's someone who feels as
though they have some sort of original
thought it's like when i walk walk by
someone in the airport and they're like
hey minimalist i figured you'd be
traveling with no bags so you'd be
riding a donkey yeah
and it's like okay you can feel that way
but uh you're just trying to be
you're trying to joke or whatever right
right but to answer it seriously is then
to take all the fun the humor the
joy out of it and so what i will often
do i remember recently i posted a a
picture of like when i was moving i
posted it on instagram and it was like
four or five boxes in my kitchen of
everything and uh and several people i
think danny was one of them right
several people were like oh you call
yourself a minimalist jokingly yeah
instead of like being defensive at all i
said oh it's not mine i swear i'm
holding it for a friend yeah yeah right
did you enjoy this stand-alone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free